- Bem-vindo de volta a Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Meu nome é John Watrous e
sou o diretor técnico do IBM Quantum Education.
Esta é a sexta aula da série e é a segunda aula da
segunda unidade, que trata de algoritmos quânticos.
Na aula anterior, discutimos o modelo de consulta
de computação, e vimos que nesse modelo, algoritmos quânticos podem
oferecer uma vantagem surpreendente
sobre algoritmos clássicos, incluindo uma vantagem exponencial no caso do problema de Simon.
Infelizmente, o modelo de consulta
não tem nenhuma relevância prática direta ou imediata.
A noção de caixa preta é uma abstração
muito útil, como se verifica, mas temos algum trabalho a
fazer se quisermos aplicar
os insights que obtivemos do modelo de consulta a um contexto computacional mais padrão, onde as entradas são dadas como sequências de bits
em vez de oráculos ou caixas pretas.
O principal objetivo desta aula é estabelecer uma base
a partir da qual possamos fazer isso.
Aqui está uma visão geral da aula. Em grande parte dela, vamos nos concentrar
no custo computacional,
ou seja, o quão difíceis são diferentes
tarefas computacionais e como podemos medir essa dificuldade.
Grosso modo, isso se traduz em quanto tempo temos que esperar
para que os cálculos terminem e, em última análise, quais
problemas computacionais
podemos resolver e quais estão fora do nosso alcance.
Vamos começar com
alguns exemplos: fatoração de inteiros e cálculo do máximo divisor
comum, ou MDC, para resumir.
Esses são exemplos muito bons para ilustrar os
princípios subjacentes, e ambos também acontecem
de ser altamente relevantes para o algoritmo de Shor, que vamos
discutir na próxima aula,
então vamos aproveitar ao dobro
esses exemplos.
Em seguida, vamos discutir a noção de custo computacional de forma mais geral e como podemos medi-lo.
Há muitas maneiras diferentes
de fazer isso, mas vamos nos concentrar principalmente em como podemos fazer isso com modelos de circuit de computação,
especificamente circuits Booleanos
e circuits quânticos.
O foco aqui será em algoritmos, em oposição ao hardware de computador,
por exemplo, e vamos nos preocupar mais
com como os custos de
executar um algoritmo escalam à medida que as instâncias específicas do problema em que ele é executado crescem em tamanho, em vez
de com quantos segundos,
minutos ou horas um
determinado cálculo requer.
A ideia que motiva esse ponto de vista é que os algoritmos têm
importância fundamental.
Até hoje, ainda estamos
executando algoritmos que foram desenvolvidos há
muito, muito tempo e, naturalmente, eles serão implantados
em instâncias de problemas cada vez
maiores usando hardware mais rápido e confiável à medida que a tecnologia evolui.
E a forma como eles escalam nos diz muito
sobre o quão úteis eles são e o quão úteis continuarão sendo.
Na última seção da aula, vamos nos voltar para uma tarefa de importância crítica, que é executar computações clássicas
em computadores quânticos. A razão pela qual isso é importante não é porque esperamos substituir computadores clássicos
por computadores quânticos,
o que parece extremamente improvável de acontecer tão cedo, se alguma vez acontecer, mas porque abre
muitas possibilidades interessantes
para algoritmos quânticos.
Especificamente, uma vez que sabemos como executar computações clássicas
em computadores quânticos, elas ficam disponíveis para algoritmos quânticos como sub-rotinas
para que possamos efetivamente
aproveitar tudo o que sabemos sobre algoritmos clássicos na busca de vantagens computacionais quânticas.
Os computadores clássicos que temos hoje são verdadeiras maravilhas da tecnologia.
São incrivelmente rápidos, mas não tão rápidos que nenhum problema computacional
esteja fora do seu alcance.
Alguns problemas computacionais
são tão inerentemente difíceis que, embora tenhamos
algoritmos para resolvê-los, nenhum computador no planeta Terra hoje
é rápido o suficiente para executar esses
algoritmos até a conclusão mesmo em entradas de tamanho moderado dentro do tempo de vida de um ser humano
ou mesmo dentro do tempo de vida
da própria Terra.
Para explicar melhor, vamos dar uma olhada no
problema da fatoração de inteiros.
O enunciado do problema é muito simples. A entrada para o problema é um inteiro N que é pelo menos dois, e a saída é a
fatoração prima de N,
e o que isso significa é uma lista dos fatores primos de N junto com as potências às quais esses números primos devem ser elevados
para obter N multiplicando-os todos juntos.
Claro, podemos sempre multiplicar os fatores primos em qualquer ordem, mas além da ordem deles,
as fatorações primas são sempre únicas para cada escolha de N.
Esse fato é chamado de
teorema fundamental da aritmética, e se quiser
aprender mais sobre ele, é algo que você pode encontrar
logo no início de
muitos livros de teoria dos números.
Como um exemplo muito simples, aqui está a fatoração prima
do número 12.
É dois elevado a dois
vezes três elevado a um.
Sem surpresa, um
computador pode te dizer isso num piscar de olhos simplesmente procurando
iterativamente por fatores primos.
Aqui está outro exemplo. Não vou tentar ler esse número.
É cerca de 3,4 quatuordecilhões, e tenho que admitir que acho estranho que haja até esse nome,
mas de qualquer forma, ele tem 46 dígitos decimais e aqui você pode ver
sua fatoração prima.
Um computador também pode te dizer isso. Fatorei esse número usando o método de fatoração incluído na biblioteca de matemática simbólica para Python,
e levou alguns segundos, o que não é um tempo particularmente longo, mas havia um atraso perceptível.
E certamente o método factor N não encontra essa fatoração prima pesquisando ingenuamente por fatores primos.
Na verdade, ele usa um híbrido
de diferentes algoritmos, incluindo um chamado algoritmo de crivo colorido, que é um algoritmo para fatoração
mais sofisticado do que pesquisar ingenuamente de forma iterativa
por fatores primos, e embora isso possa parecer
um número bastante grande,
como entrada para um problema computacional, na verdade não é tão grande assim.
São apenas 46 caracteres.
Aqui está mais um exemplo. É um número com 309 dígitos decimais.
Se o escrevermos em notação binária, ele tem 1.024 bits e é por isso
que se chama RSA1024.
A fatoração prima desse número não é conhecida atualmente.
Esse número vem do
desafio de fatoração RSA, que foi executado pela RSA
Laboratories de 1991 a 2007.
Eles ofereceram prêmios em dinheiro
pelas fatorações primas de vários números de tamanho crescente, incluindo este, que valia US$ 100.000,
mas esse prêmio nunca foi reivindicado.
A segurança do sistema criptográfico de chave pública RSA é baseada na dificuldade
da fatoração de inteiros.
Se você conseguir fatorar, você
pode quebrar o sistema, e assim o propósito do desafio era basicamente rastrear o
estado da arte em fatoração.
A conclusão é que
fatorar esse número está além das nossas capacidades atuais.
Até onde sabemos, o
problema em si é complexo demais para que os computadores clássicos
o resolvam na prática.
O maior número do desafio RSA que já foi fatorado até agora, aliás, tem 250 dígitos decimais.
Pode ser um pouco difícil
ler isso na tela, mas aqui está a fatoração
prima do RSA250.
Foi feito em 2020 usando um algoritmo conhecido como crivo do corpo de números, e foi um esforço coletivo envolvendo dezenas de milhares
de computadores ao redor do mundo.
Agora, vamos considerar um
problema computacional diferente, que é o problema de calcular o máximo divisor
comum, ou MDC,
de dois inteiros não negativos.
Aqui está o enunciado do problema. A entrada consiste em dois
números desta vez, N e M,
e vamos assumir que
não são ambos iguais a zero.
O objetivo é calcular o
MDC desses dois números, que é o maior inteiro D que divide igualmente tanto N quanto M,
e se você pensar sobre as
fatorações primas de N e M, o que vai descobrir é que o MDC é o produto de todos os números primos
que dividem tanto N quanto M elevados ao mínimo das potências que aparecem nas duas
fatorações primas.
Portanto, está relacionado ao problema
da fatoração de inteiros, mas acaba sendo muito, muito mais fácil
para os computadores resolverem. Podemos calcular MDCs de números com muitos milhares de dígitos
num piscar de olhos.
Seria meio inútil tentar te mostrar exemplos na tela porque poderíamos preencher a
tela inteira com dígitos e ainda estaríamos descrevendo
instâncias facilmente resolvidas desse problema.
Mas se você tiver interesse, siga o link na descrição do vídeo para a página do livro didático desta aula e encontrará células de código
para os tipos de cálculos
sobre os quais estou falando, incluindo os que calculam
MDCs de números grandes, e você pode experimentá-los por conta própria.
A questão é: por que é possível calcular MDCs tão facilmente?
E a resposta para essa pergunta é que temos algoritmos eficientes
para calcular MDCs.
Entre eles está o algoritmo de Euclides, que foi descoberto há mais de 2.000 anos, mas também há outros
algoritmos eficientes de MDC.
E claro, estamos falando de algoritmos clássicos aqui, o que leva a outra pergunta.
Poderia existir um algoritmo clássico eficiente
para fatoração de inteiros
que nos permitisse fatorar números como RSA1024
num piscar de olhos?
E a resposta é sim. Absolutamente, poderia existir um algoritmo clássico eficiente
para fatoração e atualmente não sabemos de nenhuma maneira
de descartar essa possibilidade. Tudo o que podemos dizer é que
ainda não encontramos um.
Para todos os algoritmos clássicos
de fatoração que conhecemos, ainda estamos essencialmente
procurando fatores
e isso coloca números como
RSA1024 fora do nosso alcance.
Algoritmos eficientes de MDC,
por outro lado, simplesmente não funcionam assim.
Eles não buscam um
máximo divisor comum. Eles efetivamente apenas o constroem com um procedimento mecânico que tem um custo aproximadamente comparável
a multiplicar os mesmos
dois números juntos, e vou dizer um pouco mais sobre isso mais adiante na aula.
Claro, tudo isso está levando
ao algoritmo de Shor, que veremos na próxima aula, que é um algoritmo quântico eficiente
para calcular fatorações primas, mas ainda temos algum terreno
a cobrir antes de chegar lá.
Em seguida, vamos falar
sobre um framework matemático por meio do qual podemos medir os custos computacionais
de diferentes algoritmos,
incluindo os que já discutimos.
Para ficar claro, vamos nos concentrar muito especificamente em circuits, que é apenas uma pequena parte
de um assunto muito mais amplo.
Vamos começar com uma visão de alto nível de uma computação comum
da aula anterior, significando em particular que não estamos pensando
sobre problemas de consulta,
estamos pensando sobre
problemas onde a entrada é fornecida explicitamente como uma string binária.
Como disse na aula anterior, poderíamos claro permitir
outros símbolos se quiséssemos, mas vamos simplificar e ficar com strings binárias
tanto para a entrada quanto para a saída.
O cálculo em si poderia ser modelado ou descrito de diversas maneiras, como com o
modelo de computação de máquina de Turing,
circuits Booleanos, circuits quânticos, ou programas escritos em
uma linguagem como Python ou qualquer outra linguagem de sua escolha.
Como disse há pouco, vamos nos concentrar em
circuits, Booleanos e quânticos.
Primeiro, vamos passar um pouco mais de tempo falando sobre a entrada e a saída, que assumimos serem strings binárias.
Usando strings binárias, podemos codificar muitos tipos diferentes de
objetos matemáticos, como números, vetores,
matrizes, grafos,
descrições de moléculas, por exemplo, bem como listas de todos esses objetos e outros também.
Como um exemplo muito simples, se quisermos codificar inteiros não negativos
como strings binárias, podemos usar notação binária.
Nesta tabela aqui, você verá os primeiros 13
inteiros não negativos junto com suas representações ou codificações binárias.
Aqui na terceira coluna, você pode ver o comprimento de
cada uma dessas codificações, que é apenas o número total de bits necessários para a codificação,
e aqui está uma fórmula simples que te diz exatamente quantos bits
são necessários em geral para qualquer inteiro não negativo N.
Note em particular que
o comprimento da codificação é geralmente muito menor
do que o número em si.
É logarítmico no número.
O RSA1024, por exemplo, tem uma codificação de comprimento 1.024, mas o número em si é
claro muito maior do que isso.
Esse esquema de codificação funciona
para inteiros não negativos, mas se quisermos lidar com
inteiros arbitrários, incluindo negativos, podemos
simplesmente adicionar um bit de sinal.
Podemos também permitir qualquer número de zeros à esquerda nessas codificações se quisermos que as codificações
preencham um bloco de bits ou um registrador de tamanho fixo
desde que seja grande o suficiente. Às vezes isso é muito conveniente.
Essa não é a única maneira de codificar inteiros como strings de bits.
Há outras maneiras de fazer isso, mas esta é uma maneira bastante
padrão de fazê-lo.
Para outros tipos de objetos que podem formar as entradas ou as saídas dos problemas computacionais nos quais estamos interessados, podemos criar
outros esquemas de codificação.
Por exemplo, pense em como
você poderia codificar um vetor ou um grafo como uma string binária ou pense em como você poderia codificar
duas strings binárias em
uma única string binária usando apenas o símbolo zero e um sem um espaço ou qualquer outro símbolo
para separar as duas strings. Certamente há maneiras de
fazer essas coisas, e na verdade, temos muita liberdade
sobre exatamente como fazemos isso.
Frequentemente não haverá uma única maneira padrão ou universalmente acordada de codificar o que quer que seja
como uma string binária,
mas tudo bem, podemos simplesmente escolher uma ou inventar uma nova se preferirmos.
De um ponto de vista puramente formal, estamos pensando em computações como transformações essencialmente mecânicas em strings de bits
e os detalhes de quaisquer
esquemas de codificação que usamos são certamente importantes em algum nível.
Mas, mesmo assim, quando estamos projetando e
analisando algoritmos, geralmente não nos preocupamos muito com os detalhes dos
esquemas de codificação.
Se você pedir a duas pessoas diferentes que criem uma maneira de codificar, digamos, moléculas de um certo
tipo como strings binárias,
você pode esperar que elas criem maneiras diferentes de fazer isso, mas se forem pessoas razoáveis que sabem o que estão fazendo,
você também poderia razoavelmente esperar que seria um processo computacional bastante
simples para traduzir entre os dois esquemas de codificação,
provavelmente exigindo um cálculo muito
direto que seria bastante fácil em comparação com o cálculo real
no qual estamos interessados.
A conclusão é que os detalhes sobre os esquemas de codificação que usamos costumam ser bastante secundários e nosso foco está nos
próprios algoritmos.
Nada disso vai ser um problema para esta aula, aliás. Vamos nos concentrar principalmente em problemas que dizem respeito a inteiros, que assumiremos estarem codificados em binário,
mas é algo para se ter em mente.
Em geral, para qualquer tipo de problema do qual estejamos falando, o comprimento da entrada refere-se
ao número de bits necessários para codificar a entrada,
e encaramos o comprimento da entrada como sendo o tamanho da instância de qualquer problema em que estejamos pensando.
Agora, vamos considerar
o próprio cálculo, que é representado pelo
retângulo azul nesta figura.
A forma como vamos medir
o custo desse cálculo é contar o número de operações elementares que ele requer.
Intuitivamente falando, uma operação elementar é uma envolvendo um pequeno número fixo
de bits ou qubits
que pode ser realizada de forma rápida e fácil, como calcular o AND de
dois bits, por exemplo.
Em um nível formal,
há diferentes maneiras de definir o que é uma operação elementar, dependendo de qual
modelo computacional estamos usando.
Por exemplo, uma operação elementar poderia ser um passo de uma máquina de Turing se estivéssemos usando esse modelo.
Para os fins desta aula, vamos nos concentrar em modelos de circuit, como já afirmei, e especificamente em circuits
quânticos e Booleanos.
Quando trabalhamos com circuits, é típico que pensemos em cada gate como representando uma operação elementar.
Vimos vários gates quânticos diferentes até agora na série,
incluindo gates X, Y e Z, gates Hadamard, gates S e T,
gates controlled NOT, gates swap, gates Toffoli e gates Fredkin.
Também falamos sobre gates de consulta no contexto do modelo de consulta, mas não vamos trabalhar dentro do modelo de consulta nesta aula, então não vamos nos preocupar com
gates de consulta por enquanto.
Também vimos que qualquer operação unitária em qualquer número de qubits
pode ser vista como um gate se quisermos fazer isso.
Para fins de medição de custo, porém, isso não vai ser muito útil, então o que vamos fazer é simplesmente
escolher um conjunto de gates
e vamos considerar esse conjunto como sendo nosso conjunto de operações elementares.
Primeiro, vamos incluir os
gates unitários de qubit único que você vê aqui,
a saber, gates X, Y e Z,
gates Hadamard e gates S e T, bem como seus inversos
ou transpostas conjugadas.
Na verdade, não precisamos de todos esses gates. Assim que tivermos gates Hadamard e T, podemos implementar o restante deles,
mas por conveniência, vamos incluir todos eles.
Também vamos incluir gates controlled NOT, e esses serão os únicos
gates de múltiplos qubits no nosso conjunto.
E finalmente vamos incluir medições de base padrão de qubit único para que possamos realmente obter alguma informação clássica
saindo dos nossos circuits.
Se nos concentrarmos apenas nos gates unitários e esquecermos as
medições por um momento, obtemos o que é chamado
de conjunto universal de gates.
O que isso significa é que
qualquer operação unitária em qualquer número de qubits pode
ser implementada exatamente
ou arbitrariamente próximo
com um circuit quântico construído apenas com esses gates.
Em outras palavras, este é um
conjunto de gates suficientemente bom para que possamos construir qualquer operação unitária
a partir deles.
Não necessariamente de forma exata, mas podemos obter uma aproximação tão boa quanto quisermos.
Isso pode exigir muitos gates, e na verdade não é muito difícil raciocinar que às vezes deve mesmo exigir muitos gates,
mas mesmo assim, sempre é possível.
Não é algo simples provar que este é um conjunto universal de gates, e não vamos discutir como
isso é feito na série,
mas é um fato bastante bem conhecido e há de fato diferentes
maneiras pelas quais pode ser provado.
Há também outros conjuntos de gates que às vezes são usados
em vez deste, como gates Toffoli, gates Hadamard e gates S, além de medições,
mas esta é uma escolha bastante padrão.
Então, em resumo, essas são
as operações quânticas que vamos considerar como elementares.
Para circuits Booleanos,
vamos considerar esses quatro gates como
operações elementares: gates AND, gates OR, gates NOT e FANOUT.
O FANOUT, aliás, nem sempre é
contado como um gate, mas vai ser
importante para nós fazermos isso, como veremos mais adiante na aula.
Semelhante ao que tínhamos para
nosso conjunto padrão de gates quânticos, este conjunto é um pouco redundante.
Não são necessários AND e OR ao mesmo tempo. Você pode criar qualquer um usando o outro com três gates NOT,
mas não faz mal incluir ambos e é apenas conveniente.
Como você já deve saber, este é um conjunto universal de gates
para computações determinísticas, o que significa que qualquer função
de bits para bits
pode ser implementada com um circuit Booleano composto de gates desta coleção.
Mais uma vez, assim como
tínhamos para circuits quânticos, isso não significa que toda função pode ser implementada eficientemente
por um circuit Booleano,
e de fato a maioria das funções
só pode ser implementada com circuits muito grandes
pela simples razão de que há muitas e muitas funções
e todas elas não podem ter circuits pequenos. Simplesmente não há circuits pequenos suficientes para todos.
A universalidade é mais fácil
de provar neste caso do que no caso quântico, como se verifica.
Portanto, se ainda não sabe
como provar isso, pense no assunto e
veja se consegue descobrir, se estiver inclinado a isso.
Agora que decidimos sobre os
gates que vamos permitir e que vamos considerar
como operações elementares, podemos pensar em quantos deles
são necessários para realizar
vários cálculos.
Para fazer isso, vamos
usar esta definição para o tamanho de um circuit.
Esta definição funciona tanto para
circuits Booleanos quanto quânticos e é muito simples.
O tamanho de um circuit é o
número total de gates que ele tem.
Por exemplo, se voltarmos
ao mesmo exemplo que vimos várias vezes, que é nosso circuit Booleano para calcular o OU exclusivo de dois bits,
vemos que ele tem tamanho sete
porque há sete gates: dois gates FANOUT, dois gates NOT,
dois gates AND e um gate OR. Se decidíssemos não contar
gates FANOUT, o que é comum, ele teria tamanho igual a cinco,
mas vamos contar gates FANOUT, portanto seu tamanho é sete.
O tamanho de um circuit
corresponde ao número de operações elementares
que precisamos realizar.
Então, se fôssemos realizar
essas operações sequencialmente, o tamanho nos diria
quanto tempo levaria,
então você pode pensar no tamanho de um circuit como representando o tempo de execução sequencial.
É assim que vamos
medir o custo computacional para os fins desta aula.
Há outra propriedade
dos circuits, no entanto, que também pode ser vista como a quantidade de tempo
necessária para executar um circuit, e é a profundidade do circuit.
Para ser preciso, a profundidade
é o número máximo de gates encontrados em qualquer caminho de um fio de entrada para um fio de saída,
o que é equivalente ao número de camadas de gates que precisamos
para criar o circuit, onde uma camada se refere a um conjunto de gates
que poderiam ser realizados simultaneamente porque não têm
fios em comum.
Por exemplo, nosso circuit
anterior tem profundidade quatro, e podemos ver diretamente pelo diagrama que há quatro camadas.
Os gates FANOUT podem ser
realizados simultaneamente, os gates NOT podem ser
realizados simultaneamente e os gates AND também podem
ser realizados simultaneamente.
Então podemos pensar na profundidade do circuit como representando o tempo de execução paralelo.
A profundidade do circuit é certamente uma noção interessante e importante e há algumas técnicas muito
sofisticadas que podem ser usadas para reduzir
a profundidade necessária para alguns cálculos, às vezes de forma bastante dramática, na verdade, mas é um tópico avançado
e não vamos ter muito mais a dizer sobre isso nesta série.
Então, mais uma vez, vamos
medir o custo computacional em termos de tamanho do circuit,
ou em outras palavras,
o número de operações elementares necessárias para realizar um cálculo.
No início da aula, falamos sobre o problema da
fatoração de inteiros e vimos que o tempo necessário para um algoritmo resolver esse problema
pode aumentar à medida que as entradas crescem em comprimento, e é tipicamente
o problema em que nos concentramos
quando estamos analisando algoritmos.
Ou seja, estamos interessados em como os custos de execução de algoritmos escalam à medida que as entradas ficam cada vez maiores.
Claro, esse tipo de escalonamento não é a única coisa que importa.
Por exemplo, podemos simplesmente estar interessados em encontrar os fatores
do RSA1024 e só isso.
Então, em um caso assim, estaríamos falando sobre uma
única instância do problema onde nada está crescendo.
Mas quando estamos pensando sobre algoritmos, a forma como seus custos
escalam importa muito e nos diz muito
sobre os algoritmos.
Esse ponto de vista é
consistente com a ideia de que os algoritmos são fundamentais, e como falei antes,
à medida que o tempo passa e a tecnologia avança, eles serão implantados em
entradas cada vez maiores.
Mas note que, embora as entradas para problemas computacionais
possam crescer em tamanho, os circuits não crescem.
Cada circuit tem um tamanho fixo.
E por essa razão, se quisermos descrever um
algoritmo usando circuits, na verdade vamos precisar de uma família de circuits para fazer isso,
e por família de circuits, queremos dizer uma coleção de circuits que fica cada vez maior para que possamos acomodar entradas
à medida que ficam cada vez maiores. Por exemplo, vamos considerar um algoritmo determinístico clássico
para o problema de fatoração de inteiros, talvez um baseado em divisão por tentativa, mas os detalhes não importam muito
para fins deste exemplo.
Poderíamos em princípio
descrever tal algoritmo usando uma família de circuits Booleanos onde, se quisermos fatorar um número
cuja representação binária tem N bits, pegamos o circuit CN da nossa família e inserimos o número
que queremos fatorar
nos bits de entrada desse circuit.
Às vezes podemos escolher parametrizar esses
circuits de maneiras diferentes, então pode não ser sempre o caso que o enésimo circuit tenha N bits de entrada,
mas essa é uma maneira bastante típica de fazer isso. Naturalmente, à medida que os comprimentos de entrada ficam maiores, esperaríamos que os circuits
nessa família ficassem maiores
refletindo o fato de que
fatorar números de quatro bits é muito mais fácil do que fatorar números de 1.024 bits, por exemplo.
E assim, tendo isso em mente, medimos o custo de tal
algoritmo por uma função, que nos diz quantas
operações elementares
precisamos para cada comprimento de entrada possível, e podemos fazer isso tanto para algoritmos clássicos quanto quânticos.
Como exemplo, vamos considerar o problema de adição de inteiros, que é certamente muito
mais simples do que fatoração
ou mesmo calcular MDCs.
Só para simplificar, vamos supor que tanto N quanto
M são inteiros não negativos e que estão representados
por strings binárias de mesmo comprimento.
Como poderíamos construir circuits Booleanos que somam esses dois números?
Bem, vamos começar com um algoritmo, o algoritmo padrão para adição, que é o análogo na base dois do método
que presumo todos nós aprendemos para somar números com
um lápis e uma folha de papel, então começamos com os
bits menos significativos,
os somamos, e isso nos dá o bit
menos significativo do resultado junto com um bit de carry
que precisamos considerar
quando avançamos para a próxima posição. E continuamos avançando pelos bits, gerando bits de saída
junto com bits de carry
até chegarmos ao fim.
Este método pode ser
expresso diretamente em termos de circuits Booleanos.
Uma maneira de pensar sobre isso é começar com um circuit pequeno para somar dois inteiros de um único bit.
Isso nos dará um número
entre zero e dois, onde o bit menos significativo é o XOR dos bits de entrada
e o bit mais significativo, ou o bit de carry se preferir, é o AND dos dois bits de entrada.
Às vezes nos referimos a um circuit que realiza essas
duas operações juntas como um meio somador.
Isso funciona bem quando há
apenas dois bits de entrada, mas se quisermos somar inteiros com mais de apenas um bit cada,
vamos precisar lidar
com os bits de carry de alguma forma.
Então o que podemos fazer é encadear
dois meios somadores e pegar o OR dos
bits de carry que eles produzem para criar o que é chamado de somador completo,
que é basicamente um circuit Booleano para somar três números de
um único bit.
E uma vez que temos um somador completo, podemos somar números
simplesmente encadeando, avançando do bit menos significativo
para o bit mais significativo. Estamos basicamente apenas implementando o algoritmo de adição padrão usando os somadores completos para
lidar com os bits de carry.
Então qual é o custo desse cálculo?
Bem, precisamos de sete gates
elementares para cada gate XOR, o que significa 10 gates para um meio somador
e portanto 21 gates para um somador completo, que são dois meios somadores mais um gate OR.
Então, no final das contas, se nossos números de entrada têm ambos AND bits, precisamos de um meio somador para
o bit menos significativo
e um somador completo para cada outro bit, e o resultado final é 21 vezes N menos um mais 10 ou 21 N menos 11 gates no total.
Se por alguma razão decidíssemos não
contar os gates FANOUT e incluíssemos os gates XOR
no nosso conjunto de gates, precisaríamos de cinco N menos
três gates no total.
É bom saber exatamente quantos gates ou operações elementares são necessários para realizar diferentes cálculos,
como acabamos de ver com a adição de inteiros.
E claro, se realmente queremos implementar esses cálculos, precisamos conhecer esses detalhes.
Mas se formos sempre a esse nível de detalhe, especialmente para algoritmos mais
complicados, ficaremos muito rapidamente enterrados em detalhes
que em muitos casos têm
importância secundária.
Uma maneira de simplificar as coisas que é muito comum na
análise de algoritmos é fazer uso da notação big-O,
que nos permite expressar
e comparar taxas de crescimento de uma maneira bastante simples
que é muito conveniente.
E aqui você pode ver a definição que fundamenta essa notação.
Suponha que tenhamos
duas funções G e H, que podemos pensar como assumindo valores inteiros não negativos para simplificar,
embora isso não seja realmente necessário. Talvez G e H representem custos de diferentes cálculos, por exemplo.
Dizemos então que G é big-O de H, que é tradicionalmente escrito
com um sinal de igual assim.
Se G de N é no máximo alguma
constante positiva C vezes H de N, desde que N seja suficientemente grande.
Então isso é sobre o que
acontece quando N fica grande.
Formalmente, o que significa "suficientemente grande" é que há alguma escolha de N zero para que a desigualdade seja verdadeira
sempre que N seja pelo menos N zero.
A chave aqui é que esses
números C e N zero são fixos.
Podem ser quaisquer números,
mas seja lá o que forem, não podem mudar à medida que N cresce.
Se nunca viu esse
tipo de definição antes, pode levar algum tempo para se acostumar e você pode encontrar recursos
que explicam esse conceito
com muito mais detalhes
do que sou capaz nesta aula.
Geralmente o que fazemos é escolher
a função H para ser simples, a fim de expressar algo sobre o quão rapidamente a função G cresce.
Por exemplo, a função cujo valor é 17 vezes N ao cubo menos 257
vezes N ao quadrado mais
65.537 é big-O de N ao cubo, e você pode encaixar esse
exemplo na definição
escolhendo C e N zero apropriadamente.
Por exemplo, se tomarmos C como sendo 18, então teremos que
a expressão é de fato no máximo 18 vezes N ao cubo
desde que N seja suficientemente grande.
Conectando essa notação de volta ao
exemplo da adição de inteiros, o que podemos dizer agora é que existe uma família de circuits Booleanos
para somar inteiros não negativos tal que o tamanho do enésimo circuit, ou seja, o que funciona
para entradas de comprimento N
é big-O de N. O tamanho real de CN
de acordo com nossa análise era 21 vezes N menos 11,
mas isso é big-O de N.
Agora não é sempre uma coisa inteligente descartar detalhes assim, mas aqui faz sentido
porque revela a natureza essencial do algoritmo de adição padrão, que é que seu custo escala linearmente
no tamanho dos números
que estamos somando, e essa expressão não é sensível a alguns dos detalhes de baixo nível do nosso modelo,
como precisamente quais gates consideramos ser operações elementares.
Por exemplo, se decidíssemos que gates XOR deveriam ser considerados
operações elementares ou que gates FANOUT não deveriam
contar como gates ou ambos,
ainda teríamos que a adição de inteiros pode ser computada a custo big-O de N.
Aqui está outro exemplo de
um problema computacional: multiplicação de inteiros.
Semelhante à adição, podemos perguntar qual é o custo
desse cálculo.
Se considerarmos o algoritmo
de multiplicação padrão, ou seja, o análogo na base dois do método para multiplicar números
ensinado nas escolas primárias,
que é basicamente apenas
deslocamento e adição quando trabalhamos com números em binário, descobrimos que há circuits Booleanos de tamanho big-O de N ao quadrado
para multiplicar inteiros de N bits.
Não vou entrar em detalhes sobre esse. Claro que os circuits são um
pouco mais complicados do que os de adição, mas se você pensar na maneira
como o algoritmo de multiplicação padrão funciona, não deve ser uma surpresa.
Em essência, precisamos fazer
aproximadamente N adições, cada uma com custo linear, e assim terminamos com
custo quadrático no geral.
Isso pode ser generalizado. Se um dos números tem N bits e o outro tem M bits, então precisamos de circuits de
tamanho big-O de N vezes M.
Aqui, aliás, estamos realmente usando uma extensão da notação big-O onde temos múltiplas variáveis, mas ela pode ser estendida assim,
e se você estiver interessado
nos detalhes específicos, vou remeter ao conteúdo do livro didático
da aula, que novamente está linkado na
descrição do vídeo.
Na verdade, é possível
multiplicar dois inteiros de N bits de uma maneira
que é assintoticamente superior ao algoritmo de multiplicação padrão.
Em particular, o algoritmo de multiplicação de Schonhage-Strassen
multiplica dois inteiros de N bits com custo big-O de
N vezes o comprimento de N
vezes o comprimento do comprimento de N. Então, à medida que N fica grande, como
dezenas de milhares de bits,
esta é na verdade uma maneira mais
eficiente de multiplicar, mas é complicado e a sobrecarga o torna impraticável
para números menores.
Então vamos adicionar multiplicação
à nossa lista de exemplos.
E para simplificar, vamos listar o custo dado pelo algoritmo de multiplicação padrão, que é big-O de N ao quadrado.
Então, mais uma vez, estamos nos concentrando na natureza essencial desse custo, que é que ele escala quadraticamente
ou sub quadraticamente se usarmos métodos assintoticamente superiores.
Também podemos considerar o
problema da divisão de inteiros, que está enunciado precisamente na tela.
Aqui estamos falando de calcular um quociente e um resto, então a resposta consiste
em dois inteiros, Q e R.
Mais uma vez, há um algoritmo padrão
para divisão e ele também tem custo quadrático e, assim como a multiplicação,
há de fato algoritmos
assintoticamente superiores.
Então como os algoritmos de MDC se comparam?
Bem, o algoritmo de Euclides acaba
tendo custo quadrático, e é isso o que quis dizer
anteriormente na aula quando disse que podemos calcular MDCs
aproximadamente com o mesmo custo de multiplicar dois números.
Mais uma vez, há
algoritmos assintoticamente superiores em linhas semelhantes às da
adição e multiplicação,
embora o custo seja um pouco
maior neste caso, pelo menos até onde sabemos.
Vou mencionar mais um exemplo de problema para adicionar a esta lista, e é a exponenciação modular.
Aqui há três números de entrada,
K, M e N, e o objetivo é calcular
N elevado à potência K módulo-M,
o que significa o resto
após dividir por M.
Não é nada óbvio, mas podemos calcular a
exponenciação modular a custo de qubit, ou seja, big-O de N ao cubo
para inteiros de N bits.
A maneira de fazer este é não calcular primeiro N elevado à potência K e depois calcular o resto.
Até escrever N elevado à potência K poderia exigir exponencialmente muitos bits, então essa abordagem não vai funcionar.
Em vez disso, podemos usar um algoritmo
chamado algoritmo de potência, que também é chamado de quadrado repetido onde tudo é feito módulo-M
e usamos os bits de
K para elevar ao quadrado e multiplicar iterativamente de uma maneira
que faz tudo funcionar.
Então este é mais
caro do que os outros, mas ainda podemos realizar
a exponenciação modular bastante rapidamente em números
com muitos milhares de bits.
Então como os custos dessas tarefas se comparam com a fatoração de inteiros?
Se começarmos simples e
pensarmos sobre divisão por tentativa onde primeiro verificamos se dois é um fator do número de entrada
e depois verificamos três e assim por diante, vamos terminar com um algoritmo bastante
caro, big-O de N ao quadrado vezes
dois elevado à potência N sobre dois.
Cada divisão leva tempo quadrático e, no pior caso, precisaremos procurar por fatores primos até a raiz quadrada do número de entrada,
e é daí que vem o N
sobre dois. Se não encontramos um
fator primo nesse ponto, podemos simplesmente parar porque então
o número de entrada em si deve ser primo.
Isso é extremamente caro porque N aparece como um expoente nessa expressão, o que quer dizer que esse
algoritmo tem custo exponencial.
Em contraste, todos os exemplos que temos nesta caixa aqui têm o que chamamos de custo polinomial onde N é elevado a uma potência,
mas essa potência é sempre um número fixo que não cresce à medida que
o comprimento da entrada cresce.
Nesses casos, as potências
são um, dois e três.
Vou voltar ao custo polinomial versus exponencial em um momento, mas primeiro, vamos terminar
o que sabemos sobre fatoração.
Anteriormente mencionei
o crivo do corpo de números, que é o melhor
algoritmo de fatoração que temos em termos da forma como seu custo escala.
Na verdade, o custo desse algoritmo não é rigorosamente provado porque está conectado com algumas questões abertas sobre teoria dos números,
mas conjectura-se que tenha
um custo parecido com este.
Desta vez o big-O está no expoente, mas vou passar por cima desse
detalhe.
O ponto principal é que é significativamente melhor
do que a divisão por tentativa porque, embora N apareça no expoente,
ele é elevado à potência 1/3 e isso se traduz em um custo muito menor e é por isso que esse algoritmo
pode lidar com números como RSA250, enquanto a divisão por tentativa
certamente não consegue.
Ainda é exponencial, no sentido de que uma potência de N aparece em um expoente e, portanto, como resultado,
ainda não consegue lidar com
números como RSA1024.
Agora deixa eu dizer um pouco mais sobre custo polinomial
versus custo exponencial.
Dizemos que um algoritmo
tem custo polinomial se seu custo é big-O de N elevado à potência B,
onde B pode ser qualquer número positivo, mas a chave é que B tem que ser fixo, o que significa que não muda
à medida que o comprimento da entrada N cresce.
Para os exemplos que vimos há um momento, ou seja, adição de inteiros, multiplicação, divisão, cálculo de MDCs
e exponenciação modular,
tivemos que B era
um, dois ou três.
Portanto, todos estes são
algoritmos de custo polinomial.
Mas quando dizemos custo
polinomial de forma mais geral, B pode ser qualquer número positivo.
Poderia até ser um milhão,
mas tem que ser fixo.
Como abstração muito grosseira, algoritmos com custo polinomial
são tipicamente vistos como representando algoritmos eficientes.
É definitivamente uma simplificação excessiva, mas como diretriz aproximada, você pode pensar sobre um algoritmo de custo polinomial
como de alguma forma fazendo uso
da estrutura de um problema para construir uma solução, em oposição a uma abordagem de força bruta
ou uma busca exaustiva
em um espaço muito grande.
Claro, um algoritmo cujo custo escala como N elevado a um milhão
em entradas de comprimento N
não seria razoavelmente
visto como eficiente, e não esperaríamos conseguir
executá-lo em entradas grandes.
Mas mesmo assim, até mesmo um algoritmo N elevado a
um milhão deve estar fazendo algo inteligente que de alguma forma reflete a estrutura
de qualquer problema que resolva para evitar o escalonamento exponencial em custo que estaria associado a
uma busca exaustiva em um domínio grande.
E na prática, a identificação de um algoritmo de custo polinomial é realmente apenas um primeiro
passo em direção à eficiência.
Se um problema é importante
e alguém descobre o primeiro algoritmo de custo polinomial
para ele, talvez com um expoente muito grande,
você pode ter certeza de que os designers de algoritmos
encontrarão melhorias que fazem esse expoente diminuir.
Em essência, você pode
pensar sobre a existência de um algoritmo de custo polinomial
para um problema como demonstrando a viabilidade
de resolver esse problema
em entradas razoavelmente grandes, mas ainda poderia haver muito trabalho necessário para atingir a verdadeira eficiência.
Na teoria da complexidade, é típico dizer que o custo de um algoritmo escala sub-exponencialmente se o custo é big-O de dois elevado à potência N
elevado à potência epsilon para todo número real positivo epsilon, e se não for sub-exponencial,
então é exponencial, ou poderia ser até super-exponencial como dois elevado a dois elevado a N,
que é duplamente exponencial,
mas desde que a saída
não seja super-exponencialmente longa, todo problema pode na verdade ser
computado por um circuit Booleano
de custo exponencial, como se verifica. Portanto, a distinção importante aqui é entre custo polinomial
e exponencial.
Não conhecemos algoritmos clássicos de custo sub-exponencial para
fatoração de inteiros.
Por exemplo, o custo do crivo do corpo de números não é big-O de dois elevado à
potência N elevado a epsilon quando epsilon é 1/3 ou menos,
portanto não satisfaz essa definição.
É sem dúvida um algoritmo muito inteligente, mas ainda é um crivo e ainda estamos efetivamente procurando
em um espaço muito grande para identificar fatores de um dado número.
Como veremos na próxima aula, há de fato um algoritmo quântico de custo polinomial
para fatoração de inteiros.
O algoritmo de Shor tem custo polinomial e especificamente tem custo de qubit, semelhante à exponenciação modular.
Outra classe de problemas que
você pode conhecer é a classe dos problemas NP-completos.
Não vou entrar no que são os problemas NP-completos nesta aula, mas você pode pesquisá-los
se estiver interessado.
Conjectura-se que
nenhum desses problemas tem custo sub-exponencial.
Isso é essencialmente uma versão baseada em circuit do que às vezes é chamada de
hipótese do tempo exponencial, mas até agora ninguém conseguiu
descobrir como prová-la.
Na verdade, nem sequer podemos provar que não há algoritmos de custo linear para problemas NP-completos.
É simplesmente muito difícil, pelo menos
até onde sabemos, descartar a possibilidade
de uma futura descoberta de um algoritmo incrivelmente criativo
para esses problemas.
Aqui está uma figura que
ilustra a relação entre custo polinomial e exponencial.
No eixo X, temos o comprimento da entrada para qualquer problema sobre o qual estejamos pensando, e o eixo Y representa o
custo de resolver esse problema
ou você pode pensar sobre
como o tempo necessário para resolver o problema se preferir.
Um algoritmo de custo exponencial
pode escalar assim.
Para entradas curtas, o custo pode não ser particularmente alto, como fatorar o
número 12, por exemplo,
mas à medida que o comprimento da entrada fica maior, o custo eventualmente vai explodir.
Um algoritmo de custo polinomial,
por outro lado, pode ter um escalonamento que se parece com isso.
O custo ainda vai aumentar em geral à medida que as entradas ficam maiores, e pode até custar mais do que o algoritmo de custo exponencial para algumas entradas,
mas eventualmente vai
ser muito menos caro do que o algoritmo de custo exponencial e não explode
da mesma forma extrema
que os algoritmos de custo exponencial fazem.
Então, se imaginarmos que
temos algum custo máximo que estamos dispostos a gastar, ou uma quantidade máxima de tempo que estamos dispostos a esperar por uma resposta,
se você preferir pensar em termos de tempo, então o algoritmo de custo exponencial só vai funcionar para entradas
até um determinado comprimento,
ao passo que, em geral, o
algoritmo de custo polinomial nos permitirá resolver o
problema para entradas maiores.
E é por isso que, por exemplo, podemos calcular facilmente MDCs de números com muitos milhares de
bits, mas no pior caso,
não podemos fatorar números desse tamanho.
Na última parte da aula, vamos voltar nossa atenção para a implementação de computações clássicas
em computadores quânticos.
Mais especificamente, veremos que qualquer computação que pode ser realizada por um circuit Booleano também pode ser realizada por um circuit quântico
aproximadamente com o mesmo custo. Além disso, isso pode ser
feito de maneira limpa, que é importante se
quisermos executar essas computações
como sub-rotinas dentro de
computações quânticas maiores, e vou explicar o que quero dizer com limpo quando avançarmos na discussão.
Vamos usar
gates Toffoli nesse processo.
Lembre-se de que os gates Toffoli são gates controlled-controlled-NOT, então sua ação nos estados de base padrão
é como você vê aqui na tela.
Note que também podemos
pensar nos gates Toffoli como sendo semelhantes a gates de consulta
para a função AND.
Isso não quer dizer que eles sejam gates de consulta em sentido literal. Como mencionei no início da aula, não estamos trabalhando dentro do
modelo de consulta neste ponto,
mas sim, sua ação segue o mesmo padrão que um gate de consulta.
Podemos pensar nos valores binários A e B como as entradas para a função AND e, assim como um gate de consulta,
esses valores são ecoados
como parte da saída e o valor da função, ou seja, o AND lógico de A e B
é aplicado via XOR ao qubit inferior. Agora, não incluímos gates Toffoli em nosso conjunto padrão de gates.
Poderíamos mudar de ideia se quiséssemos, mas não precisamos realmente
fazer isso porque alternativamente, podemos implementar gates Toffoli usando gates Hadamard,
gates T e T dagger
e gates controlled NOT como você vê aqui.
Não é nada óbvio
que esse circuit em particular implementa um gate Toffoli, mas implementa, e você pode ou acreditar na minha palavra
ou multiplicar tudo você mesmo para obter alguma prática extra, ou pode simplesmente perguntar ao Qiskit ou Python
ou qualquer software que multiplique matrizes para fazer a multiplicação por você.
E você pode conferir o conteúdo do livro didático da aula para ver isso feito usando o Qiskit.
Agora podemos avançar para a simulação de gates Booleanos com circuits quânticos e tudo o que vamos precisar
para isso são gates NOT,
gates controlled NOT e gates Toffoli.
Essas operações são todas determinísticas além de serem unitárias e às vezes descrevemos
operações assim como reversíveis, e na verdade,
o estudo da computação reversível é anterior à computação quântica e é daí que este procedimento inteiro
na verdade vem.
Os gates Booleanos com os quais precisamos nos preocupar são gates NOT, gates Hadamard e gates FANOUT,
E o que vamos mostrar é que podemos implementar esses gates, ou simulá-los se preferir, usando gates NOT,
gates controlled NOT e gates Toffoli.
Para ficar claro, o que
queremos são circuits quânticos que nos permitem calcular os valores dos gates Booleanos que acabei de mencionar
quando lhes damos qubits em
estados de base padrão como entrada.
Para entradas de estado quântico arbitrárias, a ação será determinada
pela linearidade como de costume.
Não precisamos fazer nada
especial com os gates NOT. Gates NOT são gates NOT e podem ser implementados diretamente.
E gates OR podem ser simulados
usando gates Toffoli e NOT.
Gates AND são fáceis, particularmente à luz do que acabei de dizer há pouco sobre gates Toffoli sendo essencialmente
implementações de gate de consulta
da função AND.
Para ser preciso, o que podemos fazer é introduzir um novo qubit inicializado ao estado zero
e deixar esse qubit ser o
alvo do nosso gate Toffoli e deixar os dois qubits de entrada serem os controles.
Diferentes nomes são dados
a qubits extras como estes, que são frequentemente introduzidos
em computações quânticas e vou chamá-los de qubits de espaço de trabalho apenas para escolher um nome.
Nossa suposição típica sobre qubits de espaço de trabalho é que eles começam no estado zero e muitas vezes podemos retorná-los ao estado zero
quando terminamos com eles, mas nem sempre.
No diagrama temos um ket zero dentro do retângulo pontilhado para indicar que a
inicialização desse qubit
faz parte do processo, e se você não tiver
um qubit novo como este, não vai conseguir
fazer essa simulação.
O qubit de saída inferior
é o que nos interessa porque esse é o resultado
da operação AND e basicamente
terminamos com os outros dois
então eles podem ficar dentro da caixa.
Na verdade, você poderia até imaginar que livrar-se desses dois qubits faz parte do trabalho de
simular esse gate AND,
tipo uma lixo que
precisa ser limpo.
Mas de qualquer forma, é assim que podemos
simular um gate AND.
Agora que sabemos como fazer gates AND, podemos fazer gates OR usando
uma das leis de De Morgan.
Se você colocar gates NOT nas duas entradas e na saída de um gate AND,
obterá um gate OR, então é simples assim.
E o último é o FANOUT, e para este precisamos apenas de um gate controlled NOT junto com um qubit de espaço de trabalho.
Especificamente, se
definirmos o qubit de espaço de trabalho como sendo o alvo, efetivamente copiamos qualquer estado de base padrão que entra,
então isso funciona como um gate FANOUT.
Então temos todos os nossos gates.
E agora que temos todos os nossos gates, podemos avançar para os circuits.
Vamos supor que temos
algum circuit Booleano chamado C, e esse pode ser qualquer
circuit Booleano que você escolher
desde que seja composto de
gates AND, NOT e FANOUT.
Vamos deixar T ser o número de gates em C e vamos dar o nome F à função que C calcula.
Então podemos pensar em F como tendo a forma que você vê aqui, onde N é o número de bits de entrada de C,
M é o número de bits de saída e sigma é o alfabeto binário.
E o que fazemos é simplesmente percorrer um a um os gates de C.
Deixamos os gates NOT como estão e substituímos os outros pelas simulações
que acabei de descrever.
Então, se C se parece com isso, então o que obtemos é um circuit
R que se parece com isso.
Neste diagrama, todos
os qubits de espaço de trabalho que precisamos para as simulações foram retirados de suas caixas e coletados na parte inferior.
Então K é o número total de
qubits de espaço de trabalho que precisamos, que é um para cada um dos gates de C, exceto os gates NOT.
Para a saída de R, temos os qubits que
correspondem à saída de C, e aqui esses qubits
são representados no topo,
embora na verdade não vá importar ao final de tudo isso
se eles estão no topo ou não.
Para ser preciso, assumindo que executamos R em um estado de base padrão correspondendo a uma
string X arbitrária de N bits,
esses M qubits de saída estarão no estado de base padrão
correspondente a F de X.
Também temos todos os qubits restantes dos gates AND e OR.
Ainda precisamos dar conta deles, e se os juntarmos todos, eles estarão em algum estado de base padrão.
Qualquer que seja o estado de base padrão, tem que ser alguma função da string X, e vamos dar
o nome G a essa função.
Então G é uma nova função que é
determinada pelos gates de C que nos diz em que estado
esses qubits restantes estão
depois que R é executado. G é a próxima letra depois de F, então essa é uma razão para
chamar essa função de G,
mas outra razão para chamá-la de G é porque G é abreviação de garbage (lixo).
Esses são todos qubits de lixo, e em particular,
temos dois qubits de lixo para cada gate AND e para cada gate OR.
O número total de gates
que precisamos é big-O de T.
Isso porque para cada gate de C, precisamos de um número limitado de gates quânticos.
O gate OR é o mais caro. Para aquele, precisamos de três gates NOT junto com um gate Toffoli,
e um gate Toffoli nos custa 15 gates do nosso conjunto padrão de gates.
Então isso é no máximo 18 gates
em R para cada gate de C.
Se você quisesse otimizar isso, poderia, mas para fins de
uma análise assintótica aproximada, podemos simplesmente dizer que
R tem big-O de T gates.
Então conseguimos
calcular a mesma função F que o circuit Booleano original
C calculava,
e fizemos isso a um custo que é linear no tamanho de C.
Se tudo o que nos importa é
calcular essa função F, então terminamos.
Mas infelizmente, temos
esses qubits de lixo e esses qubits de lixo
vão geralmente arruinar
os padrões de interferência que fazem os algoritmos quânticos funcionarem se tentarmos usar esse
circuit R como sub-rotina
dentro de um algoritmo quântico maior.
Mas podemos de fato nos
livrar desse lixo, e a maneira como podemos fazer isso é fazer uso do fato de que o circuit R pode ser invertido,
ou em outras palavras, podemos
executá-lo ao contrário.
Para ilustrar como isso funciona, vamos imaginar que primeiro executamos R e depois executamos R ao contrário,
o que podemos expressar como R dagger.
Para ficar claro sobre isso, o que significa é que aplicamos os gates
de R na ordem inversa e tomamos os inversos
de cada um dos gates.
Gates NOT, gates controlled NOT
e gates Toffoli são na verdade seus próprios inversos, portanto, se estamos pensando em
termos desses gates,
então R dagger é realmente apenas R com os gates fornecidos
na ordem inversa.
Mas em geral, sempre podemos executar qualquer circuit quântico unitário ao contrário da maneira que acabei de descrever,
o que significa que aplicamos os
gates na ordem inversa e substituímos cada um dos
gates individuais pelo seu inverso.
Se fizéssemos isso, descobriríamos que primeiro executar R e depois executar R ao contrário não faz nada.
Então, se começamos em um estado de base padrão como temos aqui, então terminaríamos exatamente no mesmo estado de base padrão.
Claro, fazer apenas
isso não é muito útil, mas o que podemos fazer é introduzir um monte de qubits extras e especificamente,
são M qubits onde M é o número de bits de saída do circuit C.
Esses qubits adicionais podem
estar em qualquer estado quântico, mas para explicar como isso funciona, vamos assumir que estão em um estado de base padrão
correspondendo a alguma string Y. Então Y é uma string de M bits, e o que podemos fazer é realizar
um monte de gates controlled NOT
como você vê aqui, que efetivamente aplica XOR da string F de X
sobre a string Y armazenada
nesses M qubits inferiores.
E assim a saída de
todo o cálculo é como aparece na tela.
X e Y são strings binárias arbitrárias. X tem M bits e Y tem M bits, e também precisamos de K qubits de espaço de trabalho.
Quando executamos R, calculamos F de X e essa string é armazenada
nos M qubits superiores, mas também temos um
monte de qubits de lixo,
então aplicamos XOR da saída F de
X sobre os M qubits inferiores e depois executamos R ao contrário
para limpar o lixo.
Devo salientar que é importante que R seja determinístico.
Se esses M qubits superiores pudessem estar em alguma superposição de
estados de base padrão, isso não funcionaria corretamente,
mas isso funciona quando
R é determinístico.
Então, se compararmos o circuit quântico que acabamos de construir com o circuit Booleano original C, vemos que ele basicamente
funciona da mesma maneira
que um gate de consulta funciona
para uma função arbitrária.
Há uma diferença aqui, que é que precisamos
desses qubits de espaço de trabalho para fazer tudo funcionar, mas de outro modo efetivamente construímos um gate de consulta
ou um circuit de consulta para qualquer função que C calcule.
Também conseguimos, aliás, retornar os qubits de espaço de trabalho ao seu estado inicial, então eles poderiam em princípio ser reutilizados
como qubits de espaço de trabalho para
computações subsequentes.
Se quisermos, podemos colocar uma caixa em torno de todo o circuit quântico e chamá-lo de Q e a relação com
C fica mais clara.
O circuit Q será
maior do que C em geral. Precisamos de alguns gates quânticos em Q para cada gate de C,
e também precisamos dos gates controlled NOT no meio, mas o número ainda é
linear no tamanho de C.
Também deve ser observado que este é um procedimento completamente geral que funciona para qualquer circuit Booleano, e não tentamos de forma alguma otimizar Q.
Para um circuit C específico, pode muito bem haver
maneiras de reduzir o tamanho de Q, e isso inclui usar métodos
que reduzem o número de
qubits de espaço de trabalho necessários, caso isso seja algo
que queremos fazer, e esse é o procedimento para executar
computações clássicas
em um computador quântico.
É bastante simples, mas é uma coisa importante
de se poder fazer.
Em particular, agora que
sabemos como fazer isso, somos livres para usar quaisquer computações clássicas que quisermos
dentro de computações quânticas, desde que sigamos essa forma onde a entrada é ecoada e a saída é aplicada via XOR
em um conjunto de qubits
assim como tínhamos para gates de consulta.
O custo escala linearmente. Então, por exemplo, podemos
criar circuits quânticos para problemas como adição de inteiros,
multiplicação, divisão, cálculo de MDCs e exponenciação modular, e tudo isso pode ser feito com o mesmo custo assintótico
que para circuits Booleanos.
Precisamos de qubits de espaço de trabalho para fazer isso, mas pelo menos eles estão disponíveis para serem reutilizados quando
terminarmos com eles.
Uma observação final que vale a pena mencionar é que esse método nos fornece um método para implementar gates de consulta,
o que aludei na aula anterior.
que aludi na aula anterior.
Ou seja, se temos um algoritmo de consulta que recebe alguma função F como entrada, e temos uma maneira de calcular
F com um circuit Booleano,
então podemos seguir esse procedimento para construir um gate de consulta para essa função e depois executar nosso algoritmo de consulta sobre ele.
Se isso é ou não uma coisa útil de fazer depende do problema de consulta em si e do que estamos tentando realizar, mas em essência, essa
construção nos fornece
uma maneira de conectar o modelo de consulta a um modelo de computação mais padrão.
É nesse sentido que o algoritmo de Shor para fatoração de inteiros funciona.
Vamos construir
circuits quânticos como este a partir de algumas das operações aritméticas que discutimos anteriormente na aula.
E fazendo isso,
damos aos circuits quânticos a capacidade de avaliar essas operações em superposições de estados clássicos.
E como veremos, isso nos permite fatorar inteiros de forma eficiente.
Este é o fim desta aula, que se concentrou principalmente em estabelecer uma base
para algoritmos quânticos em um framework computacional padrão sem caixa preta.
Falamos sobre custo computacional principalmente pela ótica de problemas conectados com a teoria dos números básica.
Discutimos custo polinomial
versus exponencial para tarefas computacionais, e vimos como computações clássicas
podem ser implementadas por circuits quânticos de maneira limpa e livre de lixo que permite que sejam usadas como sub-rotinas
dentro de computações quânticas maiores.
Espero que você se junte a mim na próxima aula, onde veremos como o algoritmo de Shor coloca essas ideias em uso, nos permitindo fatorar
inteiros com custo polinomial.
Até a próxima.